okay we're live welcome to the stream
very exciting stream tonight I think it
will be
it is sort of April Fool's Day early
obviously I'm not going to apologize and
do a huge maiya culpa over the Russia
Gate hoax I'll explain more in a second
I will explain the silly nature of the
calls for me to apologize apologize for
what I will play for you exactly what I
said a year ago funny thing by the way
as I mentioned I'm just gonna give a
little bit of time for people to join
the stream just before starting to
stream tonight I got a couple of those
calls from IRS scammers and I was able
to get quickly enough to the microphone
and record them and I insisted that my
name was Seltzer kolinsky and with the
first one it didn't work and I just
immediately called the same number back
and got somebody else and it worked and
they thought they were gonna get I guess
like fifty two hundred dollars out of me
because of the trouble that big Seltzer
got me into and we're gonna maybe edit
it together and put it online for people
to check out it should it struck me as
funny I mean maybe other people won't
find it funny but I did text Kyle about
it I want to make sure I have his okay
about publishing it and in fact it seems
like he does say it's okay so that's
something that we will be publishing at
some point soon so yeah anyway there if
you believed that call you would have
thought that Seltzer kolinsky was fifty
two hundred dollars delinquent on taxes
and was just on the verge of getting
arrested and obviously that didn't
happen I'm gonna be able to stream
hopefully without getting arrested let
me put it this way if I get arrested
during the stream I don't think it's
going to be because of unpaid seltzer
profits let me put it that way
okay so let's I want to have a
conversation today we will be I'll be
hearing from the audience a little bit
later but let me sort of sort of lay out
what's going on here
but first I'll just welcome everybody to
the stream streams are live except if
they're replays you can communicate with
me the best way is by you
the super chat function that's the
dollar sign at the bottom of the chat
window you can ask me a question you can
send a comment they will pop up on the
screen and I will answer them and
address them please sign up for
membership coupon codes in the
descriptions phone lines will open after
10 new members don't troll the live chat
there are moderators I actually had to
ban two people before we even started
for one for anti-semitism one for
deliberate trolling and then you can use
the join button down below to become a
YouTube channel member so here's the
bottom line I'm gonna play a clip for
you in a second about what I said
regarding quote collusion a year ago and
at this point it's been like what 96
hours roughly since we got the bar
letter the bar scam letter summarizing
Robert molars summary of the Russia
investigation I don't actually even know
at this point how to sort of unwind all
of the toxic disinformation around this
issue but if I had to summarize it to
someone who like missed the last 96
hours and didn't know what was going on
we still don't have the molar report
Mitch McConnell has now voted twice to
block a vote on releasing the molar
report Lindsey Graham has told us that
Donald Trump and his attorneys will have
an opportunity of several weeks to
redact whatever they want from molars
version of the summary before it gets
released and the summary that William
bar wrote quoted Robert molar as being
unable to exonerate the president when
it comes to obstruction so the the
primary problem that I've had over the
last 96 hours or so is that there has
been very little accurate reporting
about what the truth of the report is
which is number one we haven't seen it
and number two the legalese that William
bar has selected for his letter has a
lot of holes in it and is not making a
lot of sense I pointed that out in a
segment yesterday which has nearly a
hundred thousand views in its first
twenty two hours or so and we're going
to get into that in more detail but now
I want to so we have more time to kind
of spread things out on the live stream
I've been getting tweets I've been
getting emails I've been getting I don't
really look at YouTube comments but I
saw a couple of highlighted comments
that the team brought to my attention
where people are demanding I apologize
for something related to our our
coverage of Russia so I thought well
let's actually go back and see what I
said when I was specifically asked about
collusion involving Donald Trump
specifically and the idea of Russia
installing Donald Trump these are sort
of two of the specific things that
people want me to apologize for let's
take a listen together to what I said a
year ago this is from what is this from
April 17 2018 so like three to three
weeks shy of a year and then you tell me
what's in here that I need to apologize
for six one seven eight three zero 47 50
let's go next to our caller from the six
one six
area code caller from six one six
introduce yourself and go right ahead
six one six are you there yeah you're
there can you standard so far oh I
didn't even know I was on uh I was
wondering do you personally think that
Donald Trump rooted with Russia like
just your personal thought as an
individual feel like that that Trump
personally was like talking to Putin and
and setting things up yeah like we think
Putin installed some Gaea who doesn't
know what he's doing in our government
and now he's just here well hold on that
that's two different let's take them one
at a time if that's okay with you okay
all right
question one is do I think Trump was
directly involved in coordination with
Russian agents I think the answer is
probably no I think that Trump was aware
that his campaign was talking to Russian
actors but I think the likelihood of
Trump personally coordinating and
anything is probably close to zero Wow
big apologize editor okay
second part is do I believe that Russia
installed Trump no not in a literal
sense Russia clearly had an interest in
Trump being the Republican nominee from
a pretty early moment in the primary
right once he be
the nominee Russia clearly had a
preference for Trump over Hillary
Clinton and they had a number of
different tools at their disposal to
help Trump right that includes the
coordinated the hacking that was done
the release of the documents coming from
those hacks being beneficial to Donald
Trump and detrimental to Hillary Clinton
the dangling of business offers and all
sorts of different stuff right so
there's a lot of different ways but if
you're asking me did Russia literally
install Trump I don't think that's
language that I'd be ready to use at
this point Wow
wait a second so you're telling me I
need to apologize because I said a year
ago I don't think that Donald Trump
personally colluded but was generally
aware people were talking to Russia
which is exactly what it turned out to
be and I don't think that Russia had
this advanced crafted plan to install
Trump but once it became clear that
Trump was running Russia as they do with
many elections had a preference they
didn't like Hillary Clinton and they did
things to help Donald Trump get an edge
which is exactly what the truth is so
for anyone who so listen I'm being sort
of tongue-in-cheek here obviously I'm
not going to apologize the criticism I
guess would be if you if you want to say
let's let me steal man my critics on
this issue you could argue that I paid
more attention to the investigation as
it was going on then you might believe
was warranted and that's a fair
criticism which we could just debate and
say I don't know what's the right amount
of attention to pay for it
to it dozens of indictments and people
are going to prison people are going to
jail allegations of criminality from
witnesses we paid a certain amount of
attention to it that amount of attention
was not the same as other shows but if
there is a specific assertion that I
need to apologize for it's certainly not
that I believe Donald Trump personally
colluded nor that the investigation
would ultimately turn that up and I
think that that's also an important
point to make one could have believed
that
Donald Trump did personally collude that
that's as you just heard that's not what
I said
you could have believed that Donald
Trump did personally collude but that
the investigation was not going to end
up with that as a conclusion that would
also be a position one could take and
you also what would have been right and
in a sense you you have not at least yet
been proven demonstrably wrong and of
course when we talk about proving a
negative that's a difficult thing to do
and I totally understand that so yeah
the the title for the video and for the
stream is a joke I'm not going to be
apologizing and if you simply disagree
with the amount of attention I paid to
the story then by all means let me know
send me a super chatter if we open the
phone lines call in I do there's one
other important thing that I think is
relevant to point out at this point in
time which is from the point of view of
strategy for the left
I remember at least a year and a half
ago making it clear that whatever your
opinion is about what crimes Donald
Trump had or had not committed or people
around him had or had not had not
committed and moreover what could be
proven in a court of law I said a year
and a half ago already thinking about
2020 2018 and 2020 or 2018 at the time
but now it applies to 2020 impeaching
Trump is not a political platform
waiting for an investigation to lead to
Trump's indictment or removal or
whatever is not a political platform it
is not a political strategy is it is not
a way to win an election and that I
obviously stand by and we will
ultimately see what happens in 2020 I do
worry that Donald Trump is very quickly
heading towards a massive massive
reelection a couple of people saying the
sound is a little bit low nothing's
looking low on my end not sure what else
I can do maybe maybe people meant on the
clip
let's listen to a little bit more of the
clip here just briefly let me get
switched over to that let's see what
else was said during this call and I
think we were like at the two-minute
mark maybe let's see here think that's
language that I'd be ready to use at
this point that's fair to say
I have another question okay have you
ever played awful one no I haven't even
heard of it okay so it goes into video
games so I don't think we really need to
deal with that too too much so listen
I'm glad to continue having the
conversation but I'm not gonna be
apologizing and that's that I will
mention I just want to mention this
again I mentioned this at the top of the
stream I just got two of those phone
calls from the IRS scammers and I called
them back oh and I think I'm getting
texts about this as well I called them
back and claimed that my name was
seltzer kolinsky and it was sort of
funny and one of the calls is like 8
minutes long and we will be posting that
to the channel soon Kyle Cole insky has
given me his blessing and we are going
to be posting that ok I'm gonna talk
momentarily about the media reaction
what we've seen from the media different
enclaves of the media in response to the
bar report I also see super chats coming
in and I'm going to mention a couple of
those in a second if people want the
phone lines opened I'm going to do I'm
gonna I'm gonna try something ok I've
received counsel from people in the
audience that I should spend less time
talking about the fact that I will open
the phone lines if we get new members so
I'm just going to mention it very
briefly here we'll see if it leads to us
opening the phone lines or not we have a
phone number 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 I'm open
to opening the phone lines we sort of
budget for taking phone calls once a
week so when I do streams we pay for
that phone system so we usually tie some
kind of fundraising component to it 10
new memberships is what we're targeting
you can sign up at wwlp.com you can pay
the normal rates you can pay discounted
rates if you use the coupon code this is
20 20
you can save $35 off of a $60 membership
if you use the coupon code save 35 all
of that as well as using the join button
down below the vid
yo all counts towards the 10 new members
if people don't want the phone lines
open by all means don't sign up and by
popular demand I if you become a new
member and you want to call in I will
give you priority when we open the phone
lines if when you type in your name when
you sign up you put in your area code so
if your name was like David Pakman and
you were calling from in Boston the six
one seven area code you would sign up on
our website with the name first name
David last name Pakman parentheses six
one seven when the phone lines open I
will keep it tally the people who
actually get us to open the phone lines
with new memberships I will go to you
right away it seems like an interesting
incentive to try someone on the
subreddit I think or maybe via email
suggested it to me so let's uh let's
make that happen if people want and if
not I'm glad to just chat and talk about
news stories and other things okay so
let's there's already a few super chats
that I want to address the first is from
saucy max ah sir with a nine dollar
ninety nine cent super chat hi David
huge fan met you at politican last year
quick question on best practice or
suggestions do you have any recommended
books for someone who wants to brush up
on tax policy and progressive tax rates
you know quite frankly saucy I don't
know that you need books for that I
think there's plenty of free content on
YouTube and articles just to understand
the basics of how tax policy works and
how progressive tax rates work I mean
listen progressive tax rates just mean
that you have steps and you pay an
increasing amount of taxes on each
section of income I don't even know I
mean it's like a three sentence thing
yet I mean you're correctly pointing out
a lot of people don't get it which is
sad but I don't know that it's necessary
to buy any books plenty of content
online I would just Google how do
progressive tax rates work how does
government Tax Policy work and I'd be
glad to recommend other books I do think
are worth buying by the way one book I
just started non-fiction book I got
through the first 50 pages very quickly
because
super interesting I don't remember the
exact name it's something like I want I
want to inform you that tomorrow our
families will be killed it's by Philip
Gurevich I believe it's from 1998 and
it's about the Rwandan genocide
involving the Hutus and the Tutsis and
it is extraordinarily disturbing
I don't know nearly enough about that
conflict and it is a really good book
and that's a nonfiction book I'm reading
right now which I would recommend to you
Sam Dean
has a ten Australian dollar super chat
g'day mate have you seen the footage of
Pauline Hanson leader of the one nation
party alluding that the Port Arthur
massacre was a conspiracy to remove gun
rights from Australians cheers from Oz
yeah I have not seen that but it's not
surprising I mean listen it's it's the
same thing as here in the United States
right that as soon as you have one of
these mass shootings some portion of the
population given a big enough population
you will always have somebody saying
that a horrible tragic a public event
was a false flag a coordinated crafted
planned incident for the purposes of
achieving some kind of political outcome
and of course governments do lots of
things that we don't like and that we
argue are immoral and there have been
so-called false flags in history but
absent any actual evidence to every time
there's a mass shooting claim it's a
false flag pretext to seize guns it's
getting a little tired and sort of sort
of disturbing quite frankly that it
continues to be allowed to sort of enter
the narrative as something that
seriously has to be debunked Rachael
Fishbein says if you don't mind
speculating had rod Rosenstein been in
charge of Robert Muller for the entirety
of this investigation how might this
week have been different you know I was
thinking Rachael that we don't really
know what impact the interim acting
Attorney General Matthew Whitaker had on
this entire thing we don't know how this
would have been different had Jeff
Sessions
I've been pushed out when he was manure
asking me to speculate and I don't know
exactly how it would have been different
but I think it would have been there
there's no doubt about that does it mean
that Trump would have been found guilty
or would have been prosecuted indicted
for personally colluding no I never
thought that that was going to be the
case but I do think the trajectory would
certainly have been different Jimmy from
Philly
you know I have a story about Jimmy from
Philly and and I guess this is okay to
tell I'm not really saying I think most
people in the audience who know Jimmy
from Philly have a sense of him already
Jimmy from Philly is a big trumpets and
he called into the show a couple weeks
ago and we put up his live call and I
think it did really well I think it got
over a hundred maybe even over 200,000
views on YouTube when he went bonkers on
the air and he got on the phone with me
a second time and that's all fine but
our team brought to my attention
yesterday that I'm trying to think of
the dates and I don't want Jimmy to
accuse me of being disingenuous but this
is to the best of my recollection over a
relatively short period of time like it
might have been a three day span Jimmy
left like between eight and ten voice
mails on our voicemail line and the
subject matter doesn't really matter but
that's a lot of voicemails and I'm a
little bit worried about Jimmy from
Philly because it's I was surprised when
our team came to me and said Jimmy from
Philly has been just leaving a voicemail
after voicemail okay Jimmy from Philly
says bar doesn't have to give a full
report and you know it no of course he
doesn't he was specifically hired to
give a report that was going to sanitize
in the most advantageous way possible
for Donald Trump
Robert molars and Vista investigation if
you can find evidence of me saying bar
has to give a full report Jimmy by all
means let me know the progressive voice
why haven't you followed me back on
Instagram um I don't know I don't I
don't follow most people back I'm trying
to keep my ratio
sophisticated and elite so my follow
backs how many people am i following on
instagram you should follow me on
instagram by the way if you're not I
only follow 667 people and I have 47,000
followers so I'm keeping that ratio
extraordinarily low latest posts on my
Instagram me chugging from what looks
like a an orange pharmaceutical bottle
but is actually an Italian apricot
nectar in Washington DC over the weekend
me looking at a very avant-garde art
let's see if I can hold this up this is
me looking at art that is just a string
connected to the ceiling and that at the
Hirshhorn Museum in DC was a big was a
big thing and very very popular post on
my Instagram when I was in DC over the
weekend I went to a really great
restaurant an afro-caribbean restaurant
the menu was filled with identity
politics and extraordinary and our
waiter Ramiro recognized me and he's a
big fan of the show so that is those are
the three latest posts on my Instagram
and I encourage you to uh to follow me
there but progressive voice I'll check
out your account if you're if you're
publishing really good stuff to
Instagram maybe I will follow you um
okay I want to say thank you to Kendriya
Daniel who has signed up for a
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership Kendriya has used the coupon
code save 35 that coupon code works only
on the $60 a year membership it drops it
to just 25 bucks a year if this show is
not worth twenty-five dollars a year to
you and you can afford twenty five
dollars a year and you're still not
signing up then that's just
disappointing I'm not going to insult
you and sell you it's just a
disappointment and as I mentioned
earlier we will open the phone lines if
we get 10 new subscribers during the
show and if you want to get priority if
you want to have the phone lines opened
and you want to call in when you sign up
include your area code in parentheses
after either your first or last name so
I will see it when it pops up and then
if and when we open the phone lines I
will go to you first you
get priority on the phone lines if you
help us open the open the phone lines
okay gabber blabber says you need to
apologize for letting Louis leave get
him back on the show Lewis is the only
one who can unite the left explain why
we should decide all matters of
government through UFC cage matches yeah
I couldn't because I don't think that we
should listen let Louis leave suggests
that he was some kind of slave or drone
to use a beehive analogy that I could
control and Lewis is his own person
Lewis didn't want to be living in a city
Lewis wanted to be in a sort of
different type of more rural atmosphere
and Lewis is doing it I was just texting
with him today about he recommended some
Netflix series let me see what it was
here he says I should watch death love
robots on Netflix that it's animated
with drastically different styles some
episodes are cartoony others are hyper
realistic and some are anime or anime as
I've heard some strange people pronounce
people that are strange for other
reasons so okay yeah that's that the
progressive voice do you prefer Lewis or
pad I like Pat better well you know the
it's funny because Pat is ultimately in
the role that Lewis originally held but
the show has changed so much that they
are effectively completely different
positions the way that the show is
edited and produced today has changed so
drastically since Lewis was last on the
show I guess it's been two and a half
years ago at this point that the the
it's there's no comparison I mean in a
literal sense you cannot compare but
progressive voice I mean progressive
voice you were like 11 years old when
Lewis was on the show so I don't even
know like would at would I allow an 11
year old to tell me what's good for the
show I don't know that that's my target
audience
Michael Kings Michael Kings says
what are the odds that Joe Biden ends up
tanking I have no idea I have absolutely
no idea now to be clear when you say
ends up tanking I haven't missed a Joe
Biden 20/20 whoa those word a joint
20/20 announcement have I Joe Biden will
meet with advisors to discuss how he
would roll out a 20/20 White House run
which he could announce as late as
Easter week when is Easter it's near
Passover right Joe Biden wants to
declare whether he will run for
president as late as Easter week
according to people familiar with the
matter and he plans to meet with top
advisors next week to discuss how he
would roll out the campaign Biden and
confidants are slated to hold a series
of meetings in Washington DC where they
will talk about the themes he would
feature in a campaign announcement video
that would give voters a preview of his
platform according to someone with
direct knowledge Biden ran in 88 and
2008 he would launch a campaign from his
home state of Delaware
anything else relevant here he wants to
declare whether he will run that almost
makes it sound like he will make an
announcement even if he's not running
which would be kind of weird I mean I
don't think he really needs to do that
but I don't know I mean there's there's
two approaches on Joe Biden so for
people who don't know Joe Biden although
I haven't looked lately maybe we'll
check out the 538 polls if I can pull
them up 538 2020 let's see what we can
find here Democratic primary the back
story was that Joe Biden was leading do
we have any poll here hmm where is the
538 polling if I find it under politics
latest politics how popular is Tom Trump
the 20/20 endorsement primary I think
that that's just endorsements yeah I'm
not easily finding where the latest
polling is on this but in any case Joe
Biden was ahead of Bernie even though he
hadn't declared that he was a candidate
and there are sort of two schools of
thought in terms of what would happen if
indeed
Joe Biden declares that he is officially
running one point of view is when you
announce you surge in the polls so Joe
Biden if he's leading now if he declares
that he's running for president he will
surge even more that's one possibility
the other possibility is that Joe Biden
right now is mostly riding on name
recognition in terms of leading the
polls and being ahead of Bernie and he
sort of remembered somewhat fondly as a
participant as a member as a part of the
Obama administration and in the context
of Trump that's seen favorably but if he
declares people will realize hey this
guy's not actually that progressive and
that his ratings will decline I have no
idea
I truly have no idea it could go either
way and we'll just have to wait and see
David W sends a $2 super chat thoughts
on animal agriculture and climate change
well listen I mean I think we are all
better off if we reduce our consumption
of I mean I guess we can say animal
protein in general but some particular
animal protein which has a very very
high input to output ratio in terms of
its impact on the climate that's what I
do so I think at this point I probably
have red meat how often do I have red
meat I mean it's probably like four
times a year or something like that
there's a great little restaurant in
Amherst Massachusetts where I go when I
go back out west place is called fresh
side they've got this great a five-spice
brisket or what's a brisket noodle soup
or something like that and it's just so
good that I get that when I go to this
conference in Las Vegas
twice a year we sometimes go to a steak
house although so many people that go
now are pescetarian that even that is
not happening as frequently so my red
meat consumption is down extremely low
my girlfriend's pescetarian so at home
unless I want to cook poultry for myself
I'm basically not having poultry either
so I probably have poultry out like once
a week
and then otherwise it's fish seafood and
and vegetarian at home so I think if
everybody did that it would be very good
for the for the climate and I think it's
also a healthier diet so that that's my
take Anthony ha what's your take on the
green New Deal vote yeah so today on the
broadcast show I actually interviewed
the one of the advisors to Alexandria
Castillo Cortes who is really the
architect of the green New Deal and we
talked about the vote where 40-something
senators I guess voted president all the
Democrats I think it's just a PR stunt
by Mitch McConnell Mitch McConnell has a
long history when a resolution is
presented which is just meant to be a
starting point for debate to eventually
draft legislation that is actionable
Mitch McConnell has this little game he
likes to play where he will immediately
put it up to a vote and the reason for
doing that is that he wants to I guess
get Democrats to either vote against it
or just abstain and then be able to say
they don't even support their own bill
or whatever it's a very transparent
political ploy and not altogether
surprising kids zoom hey David I am NOT
American that's okay what do you think
about this two-year long election cycle
in America does it help democracy or
hurt governance I think it's a disaster
I have said for a while now that we
should have public financing of
Elections
we should have a specific time limit on
elections and how you enforce that is
sort of a question mark but we should be
restricting how long elections can go on
there's something called the diminishing
marginal utility on information okay
I've explained this before and the
analogy so there are those who will
argue the longer the election the more
time we have to make really informed
decisions for people who have heard this
analogy before I apologize um if you are
shopping for a car and you start looking
at first the research that you do is
going to be extraordinarily advantageous
in terms of helping you make a better
decision how many cars are there out
there what
the makes of vehicles what does a car
cost these days what are the
particularly unsafe cars that I should
avoid if I only want to look at cars
that get 30 miles per gallon or better
which cars am I looking at
so the time you put in has the
significant utility in terms of helping
you make a better decision for buying a
car but as you keep researching more and
more and more about cars at a certain
point you get to which spark spark plugs
do the cars come with out of the gate
which cars
can you put aftermarket bike racks on
that were made in China versus made in
wherever else right at a certain point
the amount of time you spend has a
diminishing additional utility to
helping you make a better decision it's
the same damn thing with elections it's
the exact same thing and you can make
very informed decisions about who to
support in three months I would argue
certainly in six months and just I mean
absolutely in nine to twelve months and
I would love to see elections limited
and also limited in terms of the
spending element which is just such a
toxic and corrosive aspect of of the way
that politics are done in the United
States let me welcome another new member
I want to welcome Frazer Jones Frazer
Jones from the seven one eight area code
and by including his area code in his
sign up Frazer
now if we open the phone lines a little
bit later we'll get priority and I will
go to Frazer
first from the seven one eight area code
I will make a note here seven one eight
if you want me to open the phone lines
at six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty and if I did that we might
hear from Jimmy from Philly because he's
all over super chats today so he's
clearly engaged
we simply need eight more new members
okay ww join pakman.com you can save 40%
off of any membership with the coupon
code this is 20 20 you can save $35 off
of the $60 a year membership with the
coupon code save 35 and that is exactly
the coupon code that Fraser Jones
has used in notifying me that if and
when we get 10 new members he will be
calling in from the 7 1 8 area code
let's see who's next here Hanzo main
with a $2.00 super chat what is your
opinion on Beto and his chance in 2020
you know I hate to say it because he's
not one of my favorite candidates but in
the last I would say 72 to 96 hours my
impression of Beto's chances have gone
in a very favorable direction for him I
think that if indeed the DNC were to get
behind him I'm not saying that they are
but if they were his fundraising is
strong he's getting relatively favorable
coverage from corporate media I think
that it would be premature at this point
to count count Beto out but when you
have a dozen candidates or however many
we have 1012 know one candidate is is a
shoo-in so from a from a mathematical
perspective I really don't know Jimmy
from Philly take my call before as I'm
not maizing the hard bastard I don't
know what you're talking about Jimmy I
have no clue what it is you what am i
doing something wrong is there something
you want me to do have i wronged you in
some way I'm not really sure but we will
open the phone lines if and only if we
get to 10 new subscribers we're at 2 so
we need 8 more and just out of curiosity
sure because I got this report that
Jimmy was leaving voicemail after
voicemail
yeah Jimmy just left a voicemail that's
interesting Jimmy's on fire let me just
go back let me see if I can play this if
I go back a few days this is just this
is completely unfiltered I don't know
what we're about to hear but Jimmy was
leaving voicemails at 9:00 p.m. on
Tuesday night and he left voicemails at
close to midnight on Monday night let's
just take a listen here here's just a
random voicemail from David Jimmy from
Philly debate the heart bastard this
would be like the Superbowl of debate
what is that accent you baked a hard
bastard bastard that's interesting I
thought that was more of like a northern
Northern Plains thing and just again
we're just picking randomly here
here's another Jimmy from Philly
voicemail calling it very focused on me
I'm David Jimmy from Philly
yeah debate me on this trumps AG mower
escape my reported as a scam please
please David please I beg you to baby on
this please David David you are so
disingenuous you were so full of [ __ ]
I would love how many syllables does the
word so have that's a very that's a
genuinely interesting accent I've
actually we've done a bunch of
interviews about different American
dialects and this is not one I'm
familiar did debate you on this issue
please David David please please David I
beg of you let me debate you on this
issue two six seven right well okay
before we don't want to do that to Jimmy
okay that went on for two minutes though
so anyway Jimmy very very active on the
phones and and wants to call in and
we'll see if that if that ultimately
happens okay someone has just signed up
who does not want their name announced
and they are making it very very clear
that they don't want their name
announced and so in that case I will not
announce their name I am totally fine
with that
let me see if they're giving me an area
code no they are not okay that's new
member number three I will not say
anything further because that's that has
been their request and I would never
think of wronging or outing anybody okay
Nouvel costs with a five Canadian dollar
super chat so why is everybody giving
this guy money
he hasn't even taken off any clothes yet
by the way Lewis and Pat both boring
bring back Jason okay I didn't even
think that people were interested in me
taking any clothes off so that's that's
the only reason that that hasn't
happened is it seems like that would if
anything reduce the number of people on
the stream not increase it Rugel
McDowell with a two dollar seventy nine
cent Canadian super chat what is
intrinsic
wrong with the 14 words is 14 words that
Hitler thing 14 words I think it is 14
words uh yeah okay it's that it's the
Hitler thing right yeah hope that was
worth 279 for you of my friend but it
certainly wouldn't be to me that's for
that's for sure
it's always funny when people uh yeah
anyway don't don't really know too much
what what else to save that okay from oh
and the other thing I want to do just
before we go too much further is let me
take a quick look at the regular chat
because there are often interesting
things in there I like to keep up with
what is happening in the regular chat Oh
people saying that Jimmy's accent is a
Philadelphia accent I know a lot of
people from Philadelphia though and they
don't have that particular accent where
you becomes like a four syllable word
people saying Philadelphia is a sad City
I've never been so I can't really say uh
what else people are glad that some
people glad I stopped the voicemail
before we heard Jimmy's phone number
some people upset that I stopped Jimmy's
voice mail before we heard the phone
number people asking me to debate them
you can call in as soon as the phone
lines open other people saying it's
actually a Jersey accent that Jimmy has
a Jersey accent not a Philadelphia
accent now there's kind of like an
argument happening about whether it's a
Jersey or Philadelphia accent thing is
it does it also doesn't sound like a
like a Jersey accent to me people like
beto people dislike beto people like
Bernie not surprising people are angry
with Americans that's that's not unusual
what else do we have happening people
like Jimmy from Philly people don't like
him people asking if I would ever run I
cannot be president I was not born in
the United States what else here
kolinsky Chomsky 22
in a perfect world that's an interesting
one there's an idea no more people 2020
Baron Trump 2020 bring back midweek
politics
yeah people if you're new to the show
you might not know that's it actually I
might as well mention this because it's
it comes up so often the David Pakman
show was once called mid-week politics
with david pakman why was it called
mid-week politics with david pakman it
was called mid-week politics with David
Pakman because the show is now five days
a week because we have membership
support and we have broader distribution
and our own studio and all of this stuff
but when the show started it was every
other Wednesday can you imagine every
other Wednesday and because Wednesday is
the middle of the week it was called
mid-week politics I was an undergrad
college at that time and when we signed
up for YouTube it was that that was the
name of the show so that's why if you go
to youtube.com slash mid-week politics
that's us and if you go to youtube.com
slash the david pakman show that's also
us but it redirects and that's that's
the backstory CW hambone says have you
done Jonathan heights moral foundations
test no I have not but you know what I
did recently do in his book the the
righteous mind
Jonathan Hite talks about studies that
have done to try to measure implicit
bias along racial lines and this is
really interesting there's a test you
can do online and I forget the website
it might even be a website that Jonathan
Hite runs where it claims to be able to
tell you whether you have implicit
negative associations towards black
people relative to white people and the
way that the test works I'm going from
memory here so excuse me if I'm not
getting it completely right is initially
the test tells you if you see a white
person click left if you see a black
person click right and it sort of sees
how quickly you can do that the second
part of it is if you see a word that is
a positive adjective click left and if
you see a word that's a negative
adjectives like sad or criminal or angry
or whatever click left right whatever
then you have to group the words that
are positive adjectives with white
people and the words that are negative
adjectives with black people and then it
gets reversed where you have to try to
associate on the let you click left when
it's a white person and a negative word
or you click right when it's a picture
of a black person or a positive word and
the idea is that if it's more if it's
noticeably more difficult if it's
measurably more difficult it takes you
longer to group positive adjectives with
the pictures of black people than it
does to group negative adjectives with
the pictures of black people that you
have some kind of implicit bias where
you more strongly correlate negative
feelings and emotions with black people
I pass the test I don't have an implicit
bias on the basis of that particular
test which was an interesting thing
because I'm I know I have implicit
biases everybody does if you exist in
the world I don't know exactly which
ones they are
apparently it wasn't that one according
to that test but check those out and I
have not taken the moral foundations
test 21st century Mouse is asking how
much are you ready to settle for with
Sam cedar well vert I've retained Mark
Geragos to represent me in the
intellectual property Fiasco with Sam
cedar and I part of the proposed deal
would include me being Sam's call
screener on Wednesdays and Thursdays so
we are currently negotiating and maybe
my attorney Mark Geragos will have a
statement to make about that at some
point soon stun ever says fork jersey
and Philly make America gay again okay
that's a perfect time I think to welcome
our newest member
Alexis Magana who has submitted their
area code I will make a note of it right
here so that if we open the phones we
can go to Alexis very very quickly
we now have three new members and if we
get to ten I will open up the phone
lines if you want the phone lines opened
up at six one seven eight three zero
forty seven fifty we need seven more new
members on our website and we will get
those phone lines wide open for you and
if you don't want the phone lines open
then don't do anything don't do a damn
thing and then the phone lines will stay
closed
Hanzo main can you elaborate on why
exactly Beto is a problematic candidate
who is of right now is your favorite
candidate from 2020 for 2020 supporting
from Texas you know I am not yet ready
to say Beto is problematic there is
certainly the possibility that Beto will
sort of emerge as the DNC's hand-picked
candidate some people are already saying
that I'm not ready to say that my only
problem with Beto is he's just not that
progressive I mean he doesn't if you
look at his political history his voting
record he's just not as progressive as
some others my frontrunner currently and
have not announced who I'm going to
support are in no particular order
Bernie Sanders Elizabeth Warren and
Andrew yang I know that there are more
and more concerns about Andrew Yang's
candidacy from some on the Left
allegations of it being a stealth
alt-right candidacy or libertarian
candidacy he's going to be back on the
program let me actually see when I'm
pulling up our interview schedule here
andrew is going to be back next Tuesday
and Wednesday we're gonna have a
two-part interview with Andrew yang
Tuesday and Wednesday I'm gonna address
every single one of these issues with
Andrew yang his ubi proposal which some
on the Left are furious with his know
free college tuition not proposal
position which some on the Left are not
pleased with we're gonna deal with it
all with Andrew yang next week and in
all seriousness if you have things you
want me to address with him by all means
get in touch probably via e-mail or you
can super chat or whatever works for you
Channing of who got a or Fugate or fu
gate do you think some left talk-show
hosts do the left a disfavor for winning
elections they relentlessly attack quote
corporate Democrats so much that if one
won the primary their audience will not
vote no I don't think so
um I mean listen the idea so so
basically what you would be dealing with
is the slice of people that watch some
left-wing shows that attack corporate
Democrats and who if the wrong Democrat
one would choose not to vote de-facto
helping the Republican win I just think
it's a very tiny slice of all left-wing
audiences I know they exist I know
they're out there and some of them stay
at home in the 2016 election for example
but I don't think that on our list of
problems I don't think that that is
super high on the list nouvelle Coast's
says what's your position on sanctions
as a foreign policy tool thenation.com
had a 20-18 article making the case that
leftists should abandon them so i there
are very good arguments to be made
against sanctions as a foreign policy
tool however I think that in a vacuum
just saying we are not only never going
to impose sanctions again we are going
to lift all sanctions that are currently
in place I think that that's a form of
what you might call universal
disarmament which I would oppose but I
do question the value of sanctions as a
long-term a foreign policy tool and I'm
actually I've got a book on my on my
coffee table I don't remember the title
but it is it is about foreign policy and
sanctions is a big part of that okay CW
hambone your morals org do the test on
stream sometime yeah that's an
interesting idea let's say your morals
dot or I'm not gonna do it now uh let's
pull it up here where is this okay you
can learn about your own morality and
ethics register explore your morality
yeah this I would be up for doing this
oh this was I think this is the website
where I did that study let me see here
disgust self scale let me see if I can
find the one about race now nothing's
coming up related to race maybe it has
some other name uh moral foundations
questionnaire revised yeah I think this
is the one and I have to register yeah
like that this would be a very
reasonable thing to do on stream soon
think of this ladder to the right as
representing where people stand in your
country where would you place yourself
on this ladder that is very very
interesting yeah I'm I will do that soon
I think that's good people want me to
also retake political compass I did the
I side with test not that long ago and
then found out that I side with has some
real serious issues like for example it
identified that I was very much aligned
with Kirsten Gillibrand politically
because of socialism and of course
neither she nor I are socialists so the
I side with quiz I find problematic at
this point but I would definitely be
willing to redo the political compass
and see if my politics have sort of
moved moved at all on that okay
Savior II is the newest member signing
up using the join button down below a
YouTube channel membership that gets us
to for new members during the stream I
have been mentioning that we have a
target of ten members to open the phones
very infrequently tonight and it's being
reflected in the fact that we have only
four new members and it doesn't look
like we are barreling towards opening up
the phone line so if people want me to
take calls oh we need six more new
members either on our website or down
below and I I guess it does really make
a difference if I promote it more or
less and we will we may end up with no
no phone calls but by the way Jimmy from
Philly continuing to call in he just
left another voicemail let's take a
listen to it
David Jimmy from Philly here while all
you tell your flock of the laws
regarding special counsel invest
they cannot release any information on
anyone not charged
you know this the Democrats know this
this is why user called for a full
report
you know they can't give it this is just
more more client by you people claim it
if that's the case I seem to remember a
full press conference in fact two press
conferences or a press conference in a
letter about Hillary Clinton a person
not charged if Jimmy is right then what
was that all about
I wonder let's see what else he says
just be a man and admit that you were
wrong my god what is wrong with you got
six hundred thousand people following
you and you just lie to them by omission
you're a joke David okay
it would be a very interesting day I
think to hear from Jimmy if he's if he's
not already gone on to the bastard child
stream or whoever whoever it was that he
said I was keeping him away from or
something like that there's something a
little bit depressing I think about
what's going on here okay people pinging
me outside of the stream asking how to
send super chats dollar sign at the
bottom of the chat window let's see if I
can find it and put it up on screen in a
reasonable way I seem unable to let me
take a look at what is being said in the
regular chat I'm curious what's going on
there
different people asking if I'm going to
debate them I don't even know what that
means
a big advocate here rahm lewis is just
singing my praises saying I'm nailing
the coverage of the bar report that
seems fine people saying Jimmy seems
Canadian that Jimmy seems to be in love
with me that I'm lame what else that I'm
a Jew all the sort of standard stuff
references to unsubscribe trolls as I
call them people who threaten to or say
they are about to or have just
unsubscribed what else is going on here
a lot of interesting chat it's funny how
people are arguing with each
they're about things that don't even
have anything to do with what's actually
happening in the stream here Trump will
get his second term people saying I
agree with that if I had to bet money
today I say Trump does get a second term
I think he's rapidly rapidly heading
towards that few people agree that
Andrew yang has a hidden agenda and that
he is not truly progressive I will ask
him about that I will absolutely ask him
about that I want to have all of those
conversations with them some people
saying Andrew Yang is garbage now that I
disagree with I don't think that that's
true people referring to the david
pakman show subreddit okay so it doesn't
seem like a lot of people are getting
banned which is a nice thing to see I
don't want people getting banned but we
will we do sometimes ban people simply
because we have to and I banned a couple
people before we even started but it
seems like everything is sort of normal
in the in the chat there razor X has
sent a $2 super chat I love you marry me
okay well love you too but I am NOT
currently accepting marriage proposals I
am more likely to accept challenges on
Leech s org at this point in time that I
am marriage proposals Billy is our
newest member of the evening that is new
member number five and I also want to
say thanks to new member number six who
is Neil Irving Neil Irving signed up on
our website a couple of quick notes if
you want to get on the phone lines early
include your area code when you sign up
you can include it either as part of
your first name or your last name then I
will know your area code and if we open
up the phone lines I will go to you
first if you don't want your name said
you can put in your name and also add
don't say my name and then I won't say
your name you can also put in a fake
name there is no our website allows you
to put in any name as long as your
PayPal account is functioning and the
payment goes through or you have a
working credit or debit card you can put
in any name you want if you don't want
your name said or whatever whatever else
so that is number six for more and we'll
open up the phones
xaviar e says forge
influences mainstream conservatism yeah
it does it does that that's true fortune
has grown into a sizable platform and it
does influence mainstream conservatism
and it has successfully pushed a number
of right-wing narratives by mainstream I
mean into mainstream conservatism Fox
News and talk radio and all of that
stuff tea Dietz 20 says Jimmy's from
Baltimore or at least his accent is all
right maybe that's the case
Hanzo main is a new member that is new
member number seven of the evening that
means a three more and I will open up
the phone lines seven out of ten is
where we currently stand and I think we
actually have eight let me see here
believe we have our eighth new member
[Music]
yeah we do James Buchi no James Buchi no
is new member number eight of the
evening so two more and the phone lines
will open stun ever sends a dollar
ninety-nine super tech Pakman 2024 what
about 2028 I forget your age my age does
not matter um not because it's a secret
but because I wasn't born in the United
States so I cannot run for president
under a current law and that's okay that
that's that's okay with me it's not a
huge deal but no no Pakman 2024 no 2028
or anything like that
I was actually recently talking to
someone about whether I would run for
something locally here in Massachusetts
and I don't know that I would I mean
that you know for me it would be number
one I would want to make sure that I
could win I it would be not a good thing
to take time off from the show to run
for something that there's not a
reasonable certainty that using the
platform of the show to as a catapult
would be a likely race to win but also I
don't think I want the oversight of what
it's like I mean I'm my own boss right
and there's a lot of good things about
the situation I have going on so it's I
just don't know that it's something that
I would do RAZR X Kyle Pakman 2024 who
would be the VP though again I can't run
I was not born in the United States
Nouvel cuffs with a $5 a Canadian Super
chap will you please consider doing a
collaboration or interview with Olli of
philosophy tube his channel is also
amazing and I'd love you to discussing
politics I'm always open to
collaborations
let me see philosophy tube YouTube let
me check this out see what's going on
with philosophy tube philosophy to see
the species three hundred and forty nine
thousand subscribers very nice does some
streaming does some topical videos let's
see what do we have here brexit what is
democracy comments and mailbag why we
build the wall
Steve Bannon philosophy tube housing
three hundred thousand subscribers
subscribers stream how to fix the
housing crisis okay yeah I don't know
anything about this channel but seems
interesting and I'm always open to
considering any reasonable
collaborations for sure
ok Troy machan Roy says one dollar
Canadian super chat no question or
comment okay let me uh one other thing I
wanted to bring up is so there's this
conference that I go to in Las Vegas
twice a year as many people know and on
Wednesday Thursday Friday of Vegas week
I broadcast from Las Vegas Sam cedar
broadcast from Las Vegas I think he does
does he do when Tuesday Wednesday maybe
Wednesday Thursday Friday as well it's a
sort of progressive media meeting of the
minds at Mike Papantonio z-- conference
all sorts of different progressive hosts
are there and there are dinners and
there is spin the bottle and all sorts
of exciting stuff and this time around I
was thinking of doing some live stuff
from Vegas but I don't really know what
to do
I do the regular show and normally I'm
pretty tied up with the conference so
that that's kind of it I think the
conference schedule is a little bit
lighter this time around so I was
thinking of doing something maybe live
from Vegas but I don't really know what
it would be I could just I could film
sam cedar broadcasting live and offer my
commentary from like 10 feet away that
maybe is something to do I don't really
want to go and just stream talking to
people on the street because that can
get kinda weird some people don't want
to be going out over the internet and it
you know I have to kind of like hide
them until they say they do want to be
on so I don't really know but I'm
thinking of doing something live from
Vegas not next week but the week after
but I would need need some ideas from
people CW hambone says why did the
Republican Party change the star on
their logo to a pentagram in the year
2000 I don't know what you are talking
about let's pull up a let me pull up
what their logo is Republican logo I
don't know what you're talking about
I mean if this was just a trick to get
me to look for it but I'm not seeing a
pentagram I don't know what you are
talking about and I don't
oh is that I guess there's what do you
mean that these stars here are the
outline of what a pentagram looks like
all right what am i doing I'm sure
people are just messing with me I don't
know what the hell you're talking about
okay Noah doe Doherty Doherty invite
Richard Werner to talk about bank credit
creation uh I wonder do you mean the
idea that when a bank takes a hundred
dollars in deposits if they have a ten
percent reserve requirement that means
that they now have $90 they can loan out
is that I don't know if that's what if
that's what what would you mean master
peanut 94 what are your thoughts on Elon
Omar not recognizing who and why though
didn't know that that's what she did and
there's lots of people not recognizing
Huong why though some people are
there are people who believe Maduro has
to go but don't recognize why though
there are people who believe that Maduro
has to go and they do recognize him yeah
I don't know okay another new member
Cheryl
Schneider Cheryl Schneider is new member
number nine this evening nine out of ten
and we may just time out we may we may
time out before we actually get to ten
phone callers negan the cliffhanger asks
if I was ever the ball judge in college
football and no I was not you masked
when I was at UMass we had a pretty good
football team but I was not I didn't
participate in refereeing in any way
whatsoever
gabber blabber would you support a Louis
Pat 2020 run well they would not be old
enough neither of them would be old
enough but of course I would support it
of course I would support it they would
have my vote but unfortunately not going
to happen because of this thing called
age requirements age requirements but on
a political basis it would be an
extraordinary team not a particularly
diverse team if identity politics are
important to you although I guess a I
guess Lewis is Louis between Lewis and
Pat you would have everything from
Iranian Jewish British Lebanese as I
think Pat's DNA test revealed so in that
sense there would be some diversity
there would be diet diversity Pat being
vegan Lewis being a total omnivore who
will try any kind of food so yeah I
would support it and of course it's a
total fantasy because neither of them
will be old enough to run for president
in 2020 actually will Lewis do you have
to be 35 or 37 now I don't remember 30
35 35 and lived for seven years no you
have to that doesn't make sense either
yeah I guess maybe Lewis would be old
enough but Pat would not so that's uh
that's sort of that okay that's gonna do
it for me at this
point-in-time it wouldn't really make
sense to open the phone lines even if we
got member number 10 because I don't
have unlimited time so it's sad I tried
not promoting membership as much and we
didn't get to ten members and now we
have to end the stream with no callers
but I appreciate everyone who sent super
chats I appreciate everybody who did
sign up and I appreciate all the people
who look like they continue to leave
voicemails here even though the phone
lines are not open Jimmy from Philly
left another voicemail but I'm not going
to play it the stream is over but maybe
I will do another one tomorrow time
permitting